Kim Kardashian Michelle Obama and more  celebs wish the men in their lives a  happy Father's Day  [Music]  Kim posted these sweet snaps of her man  Kanye West to Instagram with their  little ones north and st. thanking him  for quote being such a good dad to our  babies I love that former first lady  Michelle celebrated hubby Barack on  Twitter posting this sweet throwback  with daughters Sasha and Malia while  jessica biel shared this adorable  collage with Justin Timberlake on his  second Father's Day I am eternally  grateful for you as silas likes to say  you are so much cool Michael Phelps wife  Nicole posted a cute snap of the  Olympian and their son boomer and  Chrissy Teigan shared this sentimental  shot of John Legend to Instagram sweetly  writing ten years ago I didn't think he  could get better then I got to see him  as a father I don't know how or why Luna  my family and I got so lucky in this  life  to me get my to you  [Music]  you